hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com
slash the minimalists enjoy
minimalists
hi hello my name is shannon hi
i am a transplant to utah so
one of the things that's maybe not
unique about utah but
is big here is emergency preparedness
and
pantries
basements
yes just in cases
being ready
and uh so with when covet happened just
the you know toilet paper situation made
me think that
was sort of important after all so
um but if i look at the area where we're
trying to prepare for emergencies it
doesn't look very
minimalist
so how do you
balance
preparing for possible emergencies in
the future with
uh what you actually need
yeah
in the book we have three different
rules that sort of work in conjunction
with each other by the way anytime we
say rules they're not actual rules
people are looking for rules and so we
call them that but they're really just
boundaries and they're adjustable
boundaries that work for you and it's
going to be different for me and
different for ryan
the first one is the just in case rule
right just in case three most dangerous
words in the english language we use
those words to justify everything i had
thousands of just in case items junk
drawers full closets basements uh hold
on to that magazine subscription of
esquire from 2004 just in case i don't
know just in case what
hold onto the broken waffle iron
just in case
and it seems like oh yeah okay that
makes sense just in case i guess i'll
hold on to it well ryan and i have
determined like anything we're holding
on to just in case we can get rid of for
less than 20 and less than 20 minutes
from wherever we are now that sounds
like an incredible rule of privilege oh
my god why would you want to spend 20
every day replacing a just-in-case item
well we've been doing this for a dozen
years now we've had to use that rule
five times between the two of us
so that's a hundred bucks
over a decade
and that gave us permission to let go of
tens of thousands of just in case eyes
are getting in the way second rule is
the just for win
rule so some items we buy just for win i
don't buy my toilet paper one square at
a time
right
i don't buy my toothpaste one nerdle at
a time
yeah that's what they call a little
thing on the toothbrush
that's a nerdle
and um the reason i don't is i buy
enough just for when i need it so those
are sort of like just the case size but
they're usually consumables or other
things that i know i'm going to use over
the course of some
period of time and i have enough room to
keep those things so i buy a pack of
toilet paper or i'll buy a pack of paper
towels whatever it might be right
and the third rule is the emergency item
rule and so i think this is really what
fits what you're talking about emergency
items are just in case items that you
hope you'll never have to use
and so
now we can justify just about anything
so we have to be careful with this rule
but i'll give you a few examples of
emergency items that i have so
and if you want a long answer we did a
whole emergency items podcast episode i
would encourage you to go back and
listen to it we really dive deep into
our own personal emergency items but
jumper cables for your car for example
right when we lived in montana chains
for our tires right
now when i moved to la i no longer
needed the chains for my tires so i let
those emergency items go so identifying
what is appropriate for me
not societally appropriate what everyone
else expects
and then also realizing that
most emergencies aren't
that's pithy yeah
that is totally the one that i was gonna
use ah
stole it from me oh man
yeah uh i have i have like a yeah i got
a go bag like you know in case there's
earthquakes in california so you know
when inevitably that big earthquake hits
like we're going to have to do something
we have a plan if we're my wife and i
are separate we have three different
places to meet if you know we can't get
a hold of each other on the phone
so we have these you know just for when
or just for emergency um plans but
yeah uh i mean i guess the pithy answer
would be
it doesn't matter how many buckets of
food you have you can't prepare for
every emergency
and and i think that's the problem with
the prepping attitude
is we're like well okay we'll have six
months worth of food and like i'll have
a generator and i'll have it and maybe
those things are appropriate you know
it's certain
in certain houses but like in my
apartment i can't have a generator i
don't have room for buckets of food
um have you seen the jim baker one you
can like turn it into your like coffee
table just buckets of food
stack them up and use them as a couch
i have not seen enough to look it up
oh it's awful oh my goodness but but
yeah i mean uh the thing is is like it's
you know at that proper mentality if
like you know if society falls apart
um
it does you could have six months worth
of food like you're eventually going to
run out of food if like society gets to
the point where like these like you know
prep like the really deep preppers if it
gets to that point so oh here's a good
one um
i would say uh
uh
um josh help me help me help me refine
this this is what y'all i have i'll find
like a lump of gold and i'm like hey
josh make it into that bar shape that
you always do
help me spit some bars josh i usually
just add a comma
it's true
um
so uh community matters more than your
your your prepper items here you go here
you go you you can't tr you can't trade
canned corn and ammunition for the love
and support of a community
thanks man
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free